hey 42 here NASA is not only the world's
Premier space Exploration Agency it's
also one of the most recognizable brands
in history it plays a prominent role in
countless films and TV shows and its
various iconic logos can be seen on
everything from hot water bottles to
hoodies hoodie just saying the acronym
NASA conjures images of chiseled Jaw
astronauts nosing beneath shining rocket
ships assorted super Geniuses huddling
around computer screens and a random
woman giving a dolphin a hands job wait
what for all of NASA's undeniable
Excellence over the years this storied
organization has had the odd mishap like
the time the 300 million dollar Mars
climate Orbiter was lost because one of
its software systems used metric units
and another Imperial
embarrassingly nobody even noticed until
it hit Mars's atmosphere and immediately
exploded
but there's been no blunder more Bonkers
than the batshit crazy dolphin project
that NASA funded in the 1960s in fact
forget NASA this might just be the most
absurd experiment in the history of
modern science involving interspecies
sex drugs and a woman living in a flat
chair with a dolphin called Peter so
buckle up your seatbelt and strap on
your snorkel for the titillating tale of
the NASA experiment that went so wrong
it ended up in a porn magazine
have you ever wanted to read all those
books on your to read list but you just
can't find the time well let me
introduce you to short form short form
makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books they're like book
summaries on steroids they're super
detailed so you get the book's key
points at a deep level they also have
interactive exercises to help you apply
the ideas you've just learned so you
don't forget them I use short form every
day I spend about 20 minutes during my
morning coffee reading short form to
check out new books I also use it to
remember the key points from some of my
all-time favorite books that I've
already read like sapiens by Yuval Noah
Harari it's great because short form
gives you new insights about the books
you've already read with their super
smart analysis short form covers pretty
much every non-fiction genre including
personal development business and Tech a
short form book guide that I read and
really enjoyed was Atomic Habits by
James clear the key lesson I took away
from that one is that it's not about
making big changes in your life but in
about the small consistent actions you
do every day such as reading short form
short form publishes new book guides and
articles every week and subscribers get
to vote on what books to cover by
joining through MyLink shortfarm.com 42
you'll receive a free trial and 42
dollars off an annual subscription which
is over two months free so don't miss
out on this opportunity and thanks to
short form for sponsoring this video
considering just how bad things got and
we're talking injecting dolphins with
LSD bad the project had its Origins and
some genuinely groundbreaking science
being the brainchild of a rising star in
the field of psychoanalysis and
Neuroscience by the name of Dr John
Lilly Lilly was one of the first
scientists to put serious effort into
understanding animal intelligence his
early work largely concerns cats and
dogs but it soon became clear that if he
wanted to find true intelligence in the
animal kingdom he was going to have to
study creatures with brains as large and
complex as our own the bottlenose
dolphin proved the perfect choice not
only do they do well in captivity their
brains are actually bigger than a
human's by about 30 percent and their
brain to body weight ratio while smaller
than ours is larger than a chimpanzees
and similar to that of our human
ancestors from around 2 million years
ago that's an eye-opening stat and it
led John Lilly to suspect that Dolphins
might not just be intelligent for
animals but intelligent full stop with
cognitive abilities approaching our own
so in the late 1950s he set out to prove
it and it was during a pioneering study
into dolphin intelligence that Lily made
a startling Discovery or to be more
specific his wife did she'd been hanging
out by one of the Dolphin Pools
discussing some test results with
another researcher when one of the
Dolphins nearby appeared to be mimicking
the sounds of their voices it was almost
as though he wanted to join in the
conversation
Lily was already convinced Dolphins were
extremely intelligent and as far as he
was concerned the fact that his own test
subjects were trying to talk to him was
his strongest proof yet excited about
the implications he switched to focus of
his research from studying animal
intelligence generally to the more
radical goal of directly communicating
with dolphins
the idea that we might be able to have
an actual conversation with another
species was so groundbreaking it was
picked up by mainstream media Lily made
TV and radio appearances and in 1961 he
published his research so far in a book
called man and dolphin but this was much
more than just a recap of his
experiments it included Lily's
speculative Visions for a future in
which fluent English-speaking Dolphins
might one day have a seat at the United
Nations now that might sound pretty
mental it is pretty mental but Lily's
book got quite a lot of really important
people really rather excited including
legendary astrophysicist Frank Drake
now if you're a regular follower of the
channel That name will already be
familiar to you Drake is most famous
today for the equation that bears his
name a mathematical formula that
attempts to predict the number of
advanced civilizations in our galaxy
and Drake was convinced that John
Lilly's work on Dolphin communication
was extremely relevant to his own
why you ask well in 1960 less than a
year before John Lilly published man and
dolphin Frank Drake had kicked off
Mankind's as yet in complete side quest
to find intelligent life in space when
he completed the first modern search for
aliens known as project Osborne but he
wasn't simply interested in finding
aliens he wanted to make contact but how
on Earth do you even attempt to
communicate with an alien race whose
experiences culture and language are so
incredibly different to your own yeah
you can probably see where this one's
going Drake saw trying to talk to
dolphins as a practice run for first
contact with aliens
so he spoke to his mates at Nasa who
promptly decided that the Space Race
could wait so that a man called John
could have tea and biscuits with a
goddamn dolphin and sure enough they
wrote him a massive check the influx of
cash allowed Lily to build himself a
villa on the idyllic Caribbean island of
Saint Thomas but this was no Swanky
holiday home the nondescript exterior
had a top secret lab that Lily hoped
would soon be the site of one of the
greatest scientific achievements in
human history The Villa was directly on
the coast with office space upstairs and
a pool below that was replenished with
sea water every time the tide came in
it was named dolphin point and finished
in late 1963 by which point Lily had
assembled a crack team of top scientists
to begin working on his dream of direct
human dolphin communication but a few
months into the project a young local
Woman by the name of Margaret Howe
Lovett turned up at the lab out of the
blue small islands are difficult places
on which to keep secrets and Margaret
had been intrigued by rumors of a
mysterious lab where humans and dolphins
lived in close proximity
Caribbean island secret lab dolphin pool
personally I'd have assumed it was the
layer of a bond villain and stayed well
away but Margaret had Dr No Such qualms
on arrival at the lab rather than being
gunned down by a nameless goon she was
invited inside to see the dolphins for
herself
she spent the entire day there observing
the animals and jotting down extensive
notes that she then shared with the team
later that evening now Margaret was a
woman of just 22 with no formal training
as a naturalist but she'd made some
genuinely insightful comments about the
Dolphins and their behavior so
insightful in fact that she was offered
a job on the spot and not just any job
Lily ultimately assigned her what was
arguably the most important and
controversial role on the entire team
Margaret was going to teach to dolphins
speak English
it was to put it lightly a big ask
happened to be an especially observant
individual you've probably already
noticed that humans and dolphins are
quite different even if Dolphins were
capable of understanding the English
language and that's obviously a pretty
big if there were some serious
physiological challenges to overcome if
they were ever going to actually speak
it
unlike us humans dolphins don't have
vocal cords they don't even speak with
their mouths above water they make sound
in a similar way to most politicians by
forcing air out of their blowholes
there were three Dolphins at the Dolphin
Point lab sis y Pamela and Peter
Margaret worked almost exclusively with
Peter he was the youngest of the three
and unlike the females he was entirely
untrained by humans which made him
something of a blank slate to begin with
his lessons went spectacularly well
whilst he wasn't able to form
recognizable words he was able to
reliably imitate Margaret's speech
patterns and inflections that might not
sound like much but Peter had in a
couple of weeks mustard something that
would have taken a human child several
years
Margaret was spending every minute of
her Waking Life at the lab
but it wasn't enough every second spent
separated from Peter was the second they
could never get back and when she left
the lab and went home for the night it
emphasized the simple fact that no
matter how much time they spent together
she and Peter lived in very different
worlds as far as Margaret was concerned
that was a big problem and she came up
with a truly radical solution in order
to overcome it
she was going to bridge the gap between
man and dolphin she had to tear down the
natural barriers that stand between us
so with Lily's permission she had the
entire first floor of the lab
waterproofed and flooded with five deep
sea water she then installed all sorts
of unusual Furniture including a desk
that hung from the ceiling and a bed
that stood on a raised platform by the
time these strange Renovations were
complete Lily and Margaret had created
the world's first and probably last
Dolphin human flat chair for the
following six months Margaret lived
there with Peter 24 hours a day seven
days a week
despite the radical change in living
circumstances Peter's progress so
promising to begin with slowed to a
crawl he was extremely Adept at
mimicking sounds and he understood a
wide range of simple instructions but
his ability to use the English language
or even form recognizable words
was going absolutely nowhere not long
after Margaret and Peter shacked up
together NASA sent Carl Sagan to see how
their money was being spent on Saint
Thomas
that Carl Sagan unfortunately Sagan
wasn't particularly impressive what he
saw he was convinced Peter was simply
mimicking the sound Margaret was making
with limited if any understanding of
what those sounds actually meant
worried that things were getting out of
hand Drake and Sagan attempted to
realign the focus of Lily's work
recognizing that teaching Dolphins to
speak English was likely to remain
firmly in the realm of Science Fiction
rather than science future they
recommended that Lily turn his attention
to better understanding how dolphins
communicate with one another
[Music]
the astrophysicists had some pretty good
ideas on how to do it too for example
Drake had come up with a clever
experiment to test whether Dolphins
could communicate complex ideas to one
another through their language alone it
worked by separating two dolphins so
that they could hear each other but not
see each other one dolphin will be shown
how to obtain food by following a
seemingly random set of instructions if
the second dolphin suddenly started
following the same procedure despite
having never been shown it by his
handlers it would demonstrate advanced
communication capabilities
but that wasn't enough for Lily proving
Dolphins had language of their own would
be interesting but opening up a genuine
line of communication with a non-human
species would cement his place in
history and so Margaret's lessons with
Peter continued but they weren't without
their issues
as a young male dolphin in the process
of reaching sexual maturity Peter had
certain needs and it turns out horny
Dolphins find it almost impossible to
concentrate on their lessons
something I'm sure every Schoolboy can
relate to by this point in the
experiment Peter had grown extremely
attached to Margaret and when he was
feeling particularly fruity he started
to rub himself up against her legs
giving her what I suppose you'd have to
call a good old wet pumping to begin
with Margaret Salter's issue by giving
Peter some time with the two female
dolphins in the pool below
but the arduous process of transferring
Peter between the lab and the pool was a
tricky one requiring lots of time
several people and a makeshift lift
precious hours were lost to this complex
maneuver so to save time Margaret
decided to take matters into her own
hands and by matters I mean Peter's
penis
whenever he grew distracted by thoughts
of poor poise-based porn she would
manually stimulate him to orgasm at
which points they could then continue
their lesson
despite the focused flat chair tooth
lidge and regular hand Shandy's Peter's
progress had stalled his ability to
mimic Margaret's voice was better than
ever but he still wasn't able to form
words and he was nowhere near being able
to use language to communicate his
thoughts or ideas Margaret wasn't
worried she was convinced they were on
the cusp of a breakthrough if only she
could molest flip her I mean Peter a few
more times then he'd soon be a Seaborn
Shakespeare but Dr Lily saw things
differently By ignoring the advice of
Frank Drake and Carl Sagan he'd ruffled
a few feathers at Nasa he needed
concrete results and he needed them fast
[Music]
Now The Swinging 60s are synonymous with
hippie culture and between them Margaret
Howe and Peter the dolphin had certainly
given new meaning to the words free love
but as Dr John Lily grew more and more
desperate to demonstrate tangible
progress he turned to another of the 60s
defining symbols for inspiration
mind-altering drugs
in a lovely little coincidence it was
the wife of Ivan tours producer of
Flipper the dolphin who first introduced
John Lilly to LSD and over the course of
the 60s the study and taking of acid
began to overtake his interest in
Dolphins altogether
but as Peter reached his language
Plateau Lily realized there might be a
way to bring these two very different
research areas together LSD wasn't just
being used by tie-dye toss pots intense
to get tit-faced it was also being
trialed for all sorts of weird and
wonderful applications from curing
mental illness to mind control
having run dozens of LSD
experiments on himself Lily knew all too
well and it had the ability to expand
the mind and encourage new experiences
in attempting to teach a dolphin to
speak English Lily was trying to touch
the mind of another species and he
figured a little LSD might help to
bridge The Divide and so he dosed both
the Dolphins and himself with the drug
if you're picturing Dolphins lying on
their backs contemplating the Stars
swirling above with huge grins on their
faces you are thankfully mistaken
despite several attempts the Dolphins
showed no sign of being affected by the
drug at all still the dose proved fatal
for the experiment as a whole several
prominent members of the research team
promptly quit and Lily's funding was cut
short
I'd love to say our story ends there but
unfortunately one final tragic chapter
remains
the experiment may have been over but
whilst Margaret Lily and the rest of the
research team could simply go home and
move on with their lives the fate of the
free Dolphins was far less clear in the
end they were transported to a small lab
in a converted Bank in Miami conditions
there were truly awful the Dolphins were
kept in tiny chlorine-filled tanks that
were too small to swim in and there was
no natural light
even more importantly at least for Peter
there was no Margaret
we can't speak to dolphins Lily's
experiment proved that but you didn't
need to chat to Peter to know that he'd
fallen in love with Margaret when the
experiment ended she was taken away from
him for reasons he didn't understand and
he never recovered from the Heartbreak a
few weeks after his arrival in Miami he
sank to the bottom of the tiny tank and
stayed there refusing to rise to the
surface to take a breath for several
long minutes until he was dead
[Music]
animal suicide is a controversial topic
to truly call Peter's death suicide we
need to be sure that he had a solid
grasp of abstract Concepts like life and
death as well as an understanding that
his actions would ultimately kill him
but whether or not you choose to call it
suicide soon after John Lilly's
experiment concluded and Margaret went
away Peter the dolphin was sadly no more
after Margaret got over her grief she
ended up marrying the experiment's
official photographer and they were
allowed to move into dolphin Point lab
where Margaret had lived so happily with
Peter luckily her new husband didn't
find it the slightest bit weird to live
in the same house as his wife's slippery
ex and the happy couple went on to raise
three children there the lab was never
fully converted into a family home and
it remained partly flooded until they
eventually moved out as for Lily he fell
pretty deep down the LSD Rabbit Hole
becoming something of a counter-culture
guru in The Swinging 60s and beyond for
a couple of decades at least he was more
drug addict than scientist earlier in
his career he invented the sensory
deprivation tank you know the thing 11
gets into so she can use her remote
viewing powers in stranger things Lily
mostly used his personal tank to
heighten his trips when taking drugs
like LSD and kessemer and it was during
one of those Journeys into his own mind
that he became convinced the world was
being manipulated by something called
the Earth coincidence control office
I started this video by talking about
anachrona NASA and I'm going to end it
the same way if you're all the not to
have played Mega Drive games back in the
90s the Earth coincidence control office
or Echo will almost certainly be
familiar to you Echo the dolphin was a
surprise smash hit on sega's
all-conquering Console few people who
played the game ever knew about the
strange man and the even stranger
experiments that inspired it
Lily's nasa-funded dolphin experiment
was largely forgotten about after its
conclusion that is until it appeared in
an issue of Hustler in the late 1970s
titled inter-species sex humans and
dolphins the piece was pure filth and
there was a public outcry about the
things that had been done to Peter and
his Pals in the name of science most
nasa-funded experiments end up in
scientific journals the fact that this
one found its way into a porn magazine
certainly wasn't ideal as far as John
Lilly and Margaret Lovett were concerned
but it did help cement the strange
stories place in the history books as
one of the most outrageous experiments
of all time
so long and thanks for all the fish
[Music]